from guest appearances as Street
magicians to recurring roles of
psychotic plastic surgeons Castle has
hosted a lot of famous faces in its cast
Annie wershing played the role of Dr
Kelly Neiman in season 6 and 7 on Castle
Neiman was a villainous and plastic
surgeon who secretly worked alongside
Michael Mosley's serial killer Jerry
Tyson porsching's performance stood out
as one of the strongest one-off villains
in the series for her calculating
demented doctor
[Music]
good you're awake
we can get started
rushing initially gained Fame for her
role as Renee Walker in season 7 and 8
of the series 24. an extremely tough
willful and complex character frequently
butting heads with Jack Bauer other
significant roles in her filmography
include Amelia jock and General Hospital
Julia Brasher and Bosch Emma Whitmore
and Timeless and the board Queen and
Star Trek Picard she also gained
critical Acclaim for her motion capture
performance as Tess in the 2013 video
game The Last of Us worshiping
tragically passed away from cancer on
January 29 2023
he may not have realized Chadwick
Boseman was even in Castle but he
appears in episode 12 of season 3 as a
magician named Chuck Russell although
he's only there as the red herring
suspect for the murder of a fellow
magician ghostman stands out in his
rather silly role Bozeman is adored
worldwide for his starring role as
t'challa the Black Panther in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe he made his first
appearance as the character in 2016's
Captain America Civil War but was given
his own film in 2018. he continued the
role throughout Avengers Infinity war
and end game until his tragic passing in
2020 from colon cancer he was praised
for his acting Talent charitable work
and philanthropy with many celebrating
his legacy in popular culture including
a statement by black panther director
Ryan coogler according to den of geek
hugler claimed Bozeman was such an
integral part of that character for us
both as the character and as a person
that we could not conceive of aversion
with having someone else on set although
Len lesser plays a very small role in
Castle the famous character actor is
still remembered for his part in the
second episode of season one lesser
makes his minor appearance count as a
funny distraction from an ongoing murder
investigation he's not a cop I'm a cop
and you're looking for someone to have
sex with
unless there may be familiar to
audiences from a standout role as Uncle
Leo in the hit NBC sitcom Seinfeld his
character made his first appearance in
the second season of the show as Jerry
Seinfeld's eccentric Uncle who
frequently gives his nephew trouble
about a variety of overblown
inconveniences Uncle Leo was so beloved
he's ranked at number six on Rolling
Stone's 100 best Seinfeld characters
List sadly Len lesser passed away in
2011 at the age of 88. according to
HuffPost Jerry Seinfeld made an official
statement following lesser's death
stating Len was one of our favorites we
always loved having him on the show I'll
never forget when Uncle Leo was in
prison and tattooed Jerry hello on his
knuckles he was a very sweet guy Chad
Everett was a prolific actor who
appeared in almost 100 movies and
television shows over his 50-year career
his last credited on-screen role was in
season 4 episode 14 of Castle where he
plays Jerry Maddox a former private
investigator going under the name Joe
Flynn while this role can be considered
a footnote in his career the appearance
came just before his death from lung
cancer in July of 2012. Everett was
mainly known for his portrayal of Dr Joe
Gannon in the CBS series Medical Center
from 1969 to 1976 with his other notable
Parts being an airplane too the sequel
The Nanny and Mulholland Drive unlike
any of the other Castle actors on this
list Wes Craven was the only one to make
a cameo appearance as himself during
season 5. the episode revolved around
castle and Beckett investigating the
death of a woman who was convinced she
was cursed from watching a haunted
videotape this episode's obvious homage
to horrorflix like the ring explains why
horror icon Craven shows up the Stephen
King beating you at Texas Hold'em again
yeah right Craven is best known for the
cult classics The Last House on the Left
and The Hills Have Eyes as well as the
massive horror franchises A Nightmare on
Elm Street and scream Craven passed away
from a brain tumor in 2015 at the age of
76 and is remembered as a pioneer of
horror movie making
during one interview with Bella horror
Director mcgaris Craven summed up his
filmmaking philosophy
you realize you're doing something that
means something to people so shut up and
get back to work fans of Castle will no
doubt remember Nathaniel Marston's
performance as Grant Viro in the season
3 episode titled the last call viral was
a union doc worker operating under the
false identity of a dead man but
ultimately had a verifiable alibi to
clear him of any wrongdoing Marston was
a successful actor who was mainly known
for his roles on the ABC soap opera One
Life to Live Marston played the
character Al Holden from 2001 to 2003
and became Dr Michael McBain from 2004
to 2007. after Holden dies in his Spirit
transitions into McBain Marston had
other minor roles in Law and Order
Special Victims Unit white collar and
Blue Bloods Marston died from surgery
complications in 2015. after he was
severely injured in a car accident Robin
sacks appeared as the announcer in
season 4 episode 13 in which Castle
investigates the death of a dog trainer
only one question remains who will be
this year's best in shop sax became well
known for his performances in film
television and theater over his
decades-long career he is probably best
known for his part as Ethan Rayne in
Buffy the Vampire Slayer a recurring
antagonist against Buffy and her crew
sax was also known for many minor roles
including the Lost World Jurassic Park
Galaxy Quest and Babylon 5. sax passed
away from a fatal heart attack in 2013.
just four days short of his 62nd
birthday
although only supplying a small Cameo is
one of Castle's regular poker buddies
the story of Stephen J Cannell goes much
deeper than that Campbell was a writer
producer and novelist who had a hand in
many successful television series which
includes the A-Team Renegade and 21 Jump
Street Campbell openly struggled with
dyslexia throughout his early life and
career some of which was chronicled in
the 2012 documentary dyslexia the movie
he was an important factor in the
creation of Castle and as a result he
was given a special tribute at the end
of a season 3 episode which read Stephen
J Cannell colleague Mentor friend we'll
miss you pal Cannell passed away in
September of 2010 due to complications
for melanoma at the age of 69. when it
comes to hard-working character actors
in Hollywood few were as impressive as
John Polito while his only minor role in
Castle was as a witness convinced that
the world is still in the 1970s he
nonetheless stood out as a highlight
that's a nice dress can I talk you out
of it
Polito is a unique character actor who
started in TV and movies in the 1980s
with roles in the Gangster Chronicles
Highlander and the Coen Brothers
Miller's Crossing arguably stealing the
show as the Weasley Johnny Casper
Polito's profile grew as he snagged
bigger roles in the Coen Brothers films
Barton Fink and The Big Lebowski as well
as appearing as Bigelow in The Rocketeer
and Gideon the pawn shop owner and the
crow he passed away in 2016 at the age
of 65.
[Music]